okay in this next example we're going to
look at the IMDb document classification
problem so here the the observations are
actually documents short documents which
each one is a review of a movie right so
we've got sentences in and words and so
on and there's a sequence to these right
the sequential data but the first model
we're going to fit is going to use a bag
of words representation and so in this
case we restrict the dictionary to
10,000
words in the English dictionary and
these are somehow the important top
important 10,000 words and we're going
to score our document for how many times
each word appeared in the document that
means we'll have a observation Vector of
length 10,000 mostly zero and to make
this um easy for this lab we actually
prep pre-prepared the data and that's
where we're going to start okay and
Jonathan will tell us what we do next
thank you Trevor and we also compare
that to to at least one other one one
sequential model there are various
sequential models one could apply to
this but we're just going to try and
contrast the bag of words to the
sequential one
here okay so
um the the general structure will will
follow similar pattern to we've seen um
to the examples we've seen so far uh so
we're going to uh skip to where we
specify our model and it's going to be a
very pretty simple model with with one
hidden layer here and uh this this our
our our Network specification is very
similar to the hitter's data uh recall
we have to call this super function so
that uh torch knows um well it needs to
do it this in order to be ready to to
fit okay um so the rest of the
specifying the model and fitting is very
similar to the hitters and the the mest
um as well as the CFR data so Jonathan
in this case you know would input size
be
10,000 and it's going to 16 hidden units
uh yes that's right yes and thank you
yes so this uh this is where we tell
what the input size is um and it says
well this is the the X uh the XT train
tensor and this is the number of columns
of it yeah
10,000 okay and you can see the summary
here um I oh there are three stop words
that are included three stop words yes
but uh morally 10,000 uh features here
okay so let's just
uh uh specifier model again instead of
regression it's binary
classification and uh we can make a
similar plot to the other examples and
track um there were 25,000 training
examples and 25,000
test yes and we get get achieves in
accuracy about
85% and and since this is a relatively
simple model the bag of words model we
can we can use other methods uh like
other linear methods like or regularized
methods like the lasso so the response
was sentiment which is positive or or
negative right yes whether someone likes
the movie or not that's
right okay so we're going to compare
this uh to logistic regression with the
lasso
um and I guess of note here we see we're
going to use
sparse data representations for the uh
the training and test because we have
well 25,000 cases in each training and
test and 10,000 features if those were
full matrices those would be pretty big
but of course most of the the data
Matrix is going to be zeros because the
the documents are all short and so most
of the words in our dictionary aren't
going to be used yeah so if we didn't
use sparse matrices here this would be
really very memory intensive to load and
very expensive to fit
okay so this this is sort of Ideal
problem for lassu as well when You' got
very wide data set you know in this case
10,000 and you don't expect all the
features to be important for this TOS
yes yes so let's um see how well the
lassu does we're going to um what we'll
do we'll we'll compute the uh the
solution path and evaluate test data
along the the solution path and compare
that to a um the test data test score
for the N Network as a function of epoch
so I'm just going to skip to the plot
here uh so we compare
um uh training in test error black and
blue um between the two methods and so
the x-axis here are different on the
left hand side this is the the Lambda
parameter for the lasso and we see going
from a very sparse solution to a denser
solution it has an accuracy um in the
low 80s uh which is quite similar to to
the right hand side here this is the the
our single layer single hidden layer
neural network and what we're really
what this example shows is that
sometimes the neural network you know is
not necessarily necessary to get a good
performance and in this case we do um we
have about the same and I should say at
the dense end it's about 83% I think it
Peaks here at about 88% so does slightly
better on test data but that's that's
not that big of an improvement but still
slightly
better okay so we're going to compare um
these bag of word models to a simple
well a sequential model for document uh
for the IMDb data so we're going to use
this lstm so long short-term memory uh
recurrent neural network and you can
read about the structure of that uh in
in the textbook we'll see in order to
specify it is actually actually pretty
simple we're going to combine that with
this um uh embedding uh representation
of the of of the the do of the words um
so okay
um and we'll ultimately want to compare
the accuracy so again we have to
construct our data loader for all of
these different views of the IMDb data
actually there's a different form of the
way that the data is representated
represented it's uh for the qu quential
models it's important to have a
sequential representation so each uh
rather than just reducing the document
to the number of um the number of times
each word appears we actually have to
track uh the order of the words um so so
in order to set the data up here the
documents were restricted to length 500
Words so if a document had less than 500
Words padding was used just with blanks
and if it had more it was truncated use
the first five 00 words okay and and so
we this a document now is represented as
a 500 by 10,000 um one hot Matrix that
sort of indicates you know which word
appeared at which time um in the
sequence of length 500 so this this
embedding layer is going to take these
10,000 uh these 10,000 words and reduce
that to 32 so then we'll have something
like a 500 by 32 representation of a
document as we go move along the
sequence and then we use this uh lstm
model that sort of tries to track uh
tries to fit a sequential model or some
kind of Time series model to the data um
what using 32 units which we've reduced
use the embedding layer to to reduce it
to so that's a rather you know
complicated thing to describe but
actually it's you know surprisingly easy
to sort of specify this uh in code um
okay so this is how we're going to
specify um both the embedding and the
longterm lstm model uh in the network so
input sizes is again about 10,000 so
we're going to ask for an embedding
layer of 10,000 input and 32 output so
this actually is going to incur roughly
10,000 by times 32 parameters so that's
going to be about 320,000 parameters
just for this uh and then we're going to
have this um once we reduce the the2
dimension we're going to use this this
sequential model the lstm model um to to
take account of the temporal
aspect and then finally we take those 32
units and we map to one again because we
have a binary classification task and
well the rest of the fitting is once we
specified the form of the network is
again similar to all the other examples
let's just jump ahead and take a look at
how this um how this model
performs um in the end it gets about
test accur of 85% so pretty comparable
to the bag of words and to the lasso in
this case um so we I guess I see a few
things with this example one that the
torch and other packages have you know
it's easy to specify complex models uh
this embedding and uh recurrent neural
network model but they don't always
perform better um than than linear
models or other simp
models